so this is science to it and uh raising
canes is the best though [ __ ] with
keynes bro but where's their canes i
mean they just opened one burbank they
made one in burbank so that's that's the
go-to yeah
see you you have to send somebody over
there right because it's a [ __ ] mess
dude shout out to adam a shout out
but see there's no way you're going and
waiting in that line in burbank
i'll do it if i have do you do uh cause
what i do i get the kaniak double toast
and like four sauces yeah that sounds
good i don't [ __ ] with the coleslaw no i
never ate coleslaw like i get offended
if somebody i don't even know why they
included in their meals anymore
there's multiple reasons that i could
name
but we'll just leave it at that he's got
an endorsement deal with raising canes
yeah i think i think i invested in
raising canes as well
no no no no
not yet
is it on the way yeah not yet what snoop
hooked me up with that place snoop is
the man yo he called me with todd and
was like
[ __ ]
if y'all gonna do a deal with anybody i
gotta do it
with wiz i'm like bro why are you
calling me just like trying to give me
millions of dollars like i love you bro
good guy
amazing so that's all so so you're going
to be an investor and endorser of
raising gains officially we're going to
see we're going to pull it out you're
going to be working in the drive-through
like ice-t was
he did that yeah
i'll do it for a day yeah why not it's
whatever
you got to get the cane sauce at the
crib they let you gotta do like a like a
a multiverse meal with raisin canes
that's the wave
everyone's doing meals yeah yeah raisin
canes is the wave man yeah yep blazing
blazing canes
like a like a oh i'll do my own sauce
pause that's what it'll be you get your
own sauce pause you're gonna change
pause yeah yeah you're gonna change up
the raisin the cane sauce the best part
of the restaurant
just for exclusive we're coming up with
ideas right now i like that yeah yeah
the other thing about canes is like it's
very like this is what we have
yeah we have chicken we have fries yeah
yeah we have toast lemonade
that's what we got yeah yeah they ain't
playing no games i don't think you can
get ranch there hell no you can't even
ask for it but the texas toast is crazy
texas toast is smacking is insane 100